bet it's the stupid experiments folder
again
actually okay I don't know where all my
space went doesn't
matter the docker
pull go grab it from here
chart stole that off of offer and I
stole that I don't know where I stole
that off of I stole it off of somewhere
fair okay we only have to pull one layer
not
bad we only have to pull one
layer there anything I can clean out of
here in the meantime
learning okay
well something's still not working oh no
look you've got this uh this progress
metric here train rewards going up over
time progress is going up over time
right B clip Frack is lower value
loss looks way better
oh my camera froze
lovely let me go plug the camera unplug
and replug it
go let me see in the meantime what uh
what I think I'm going to have to do on
GPU
Drive oh so this doesn't even have a
base or anything
I think I just have to fix like the
way probably just have to fix the way
it's set up with
serialization I probably am just going
to make this be a puffer native en is
what I'll
do that'll be better
fine ve
native well I don't know actually cuz we
have to see if these
are yeah cuz it's actually the we do
tensors here okay
so it has to be like VEC nun or
something which is
well I think dapne is back
on GPU Drive
image and everything is set up except
needs the poetry
install this weird Docker run is usually
instantaneous if I uh oh I got some
space
I will just give it a second there you
prior to 1.1 I got to work on like
bringing down the install time of
puffer really makes a
difference it's like if something just
installs instantly you just know it's
uh
2.5 let's
I don't know I'd suggest at least
running the Poetry
build um in the docker setup yeah poetry
will have to update some stuff but it
would save like 90% of the time for
install I guess maybe it has to rebuild
anyways
all right get
checkout what is it get
checkout
uh wait
I can just check out this this is a
branch
right out
B uh integration
right initial
puffer puffer
promising Das
M where'd it
go baselines ipo. run
buffer I is this
it wait is it I thought it was there was
like a fast run or
whatever or is this
just run puffer P I guess no module name
torch
reactivate is it like poetry activate or
something dumb hate
janky are you watching
this
uh poetry
shell all right thank
you use
UV I I used what was in the default of
the docker container this is your
container
here
okay see if I can get this working still
no module
torch
this how's there no torch I saw poetry
install it
no I didn't forget to activate or
anything
GPU Drive bin
python yeah I'm in the
torch no module GPU Drive no module
torch
present is there just something I forgot
that's not listed here like I don't use
poetry I don't know if there's like an
EnV activate or like a refresh or
something like
install surprising it's not cached
everything so maybe it does need to be
done but I did do
this
torch is this supposed to
be 0.1 on this
Branch I'm on
whoops wait why does this put me
into oh
Branch
torch what's the other thing that you
have for
this I can just do it can I just do this
manually
does this work inside the docker or does
something get messed up if I just like
control C out of this
environment I'm going to try
pip Docker has
external
um I don't know how to get out of this
thing but whatever we'll just do we'll
just try
this there's already this is already
built so I think I just need to
this okay magically works now no
idea Bizarro all I did was reboot the
anyways uh what was this
so we
got
spr
gration algorithms no was
baselines
ippo run puffer
P yeah what I've been doing for puffer
tank that's been very effective um is I
just use the docker and then I don't put
any other like VM stuff on top of it
right I use the docker as the VM uh in a
sense so like it's just a pip install or
UV or whatever you want to use no cond
no poetry none of
that that's been pretty
effective okay so there's no puffer lip
here so presuming that
you you just clone puffer lib or
something you just cloned puffer lib Dev
I need to get my own install time down
on puffer lib
geez should be
lib let's see if there's anything
incompatible in
here hopefully it doesn't mess up like
torch version or
something okay it's going to go grab
Jim numpy open
CV bunch of random stuff scyon doer
should be
fine pip install torch and M after
poetry yeah pip install e dot got it I
think
I think that was the most likely thing
that happened
um that broke it is just me using native
like VEC native for something
new but I figured that while I was add
it I would set up I do the whole proper
setup for you guys to make sure that
everything was actually
working okay so now
hopefully this
runs and we get to your same
time okay I think this is the seg fault
that uh you got to so
let's figure this
out GPU
[Music]
Drive where's your n here there's like a
puffer end somewhere
right
Ms initial puffer
code algorithms puffer Li puffer
n and this is just what we had from
here I don't have my editor on here
that's okay we'll do vanilla
difference interesting so where would
this egg fult is the question
B
um okay that's weird so this seg fol in
the creation of GPU drive itself
config in
config 64 scenes
thing there's like a puffer config
somewhere
right I not see the
config for live utils
where do you have um I had like a config
with my
original with my version
originally is that just in
here
utils utils has the
policy where does it say how many
Ms are getting passed in
is that
somehow in the algorithm file or
IPO and so here I this yeah this is
familiar and I think yeah you just
pulled all the args out of the any files
into
this
um just
fine and then where is num
NS Beck num
ends default is
eight beck. num workers is eight oh well
this is probably it right
here uh if I I recall this is different
from what I
had yeah I see why that would
ocean yeah okay so you see um
it looks like there's this new VC thing
which is vcn num
M I had this set to
one
because yeah you're doing this okay so
you have this with
multiprocessing uh your EnV is not
designed for multiprocessing cuz it's a
GPU accelerated
environment so what's going to have to
happen here is I'm going to have to
change this to like none I'm going to
probably have to make a couple updates
to puffer
lib
um probably going to have to go from
there let's see if I do cereal for now
what
happens yeah this needs to be one this
needs to be one this needs to be one do
I have zero copy on I didn't even think
I had zero copy on for you guys did
I yeah this is
false oh store true is fine
P guess that's what we're doing today
um okay
me use the restroom I'll be right back
we're going to get this to
bolts make
en wait we're in the
um yeah you don't even really need this
but whatever like it this n Creator just
has to be a function so you can
literally just pass it the class if you
want um I'll leave it for now but you
can literally just pass the class
okay so
now we're in the back end at the very
least where it should
be either way though that thing
shouldn't have seg foled uh which is the
odd
part so n config here has what's this
Max agents and scene is
128 what did I how did I do this
originally n number worlds was
128 okay so now you have 64
worlds
um I don't know we'll do like eight I
think these configs are just like like
screwed up I think this is a GPU Drive
thing cuz we haven't even gotten to the
spot where I would have broken it with
puffer
this yeah okay so literally it was just
you had too many worlds or whatever um
because like I think it was it went up
to 128 agents or whatever from before so
it's seg falting just out of memory it's
either higher end card needed or
whatever there um but now now I'll
actually get to fix
this okay so we need to do VEC none
maybe or native none or
native let me think about that
so I'll do this right now and Puffer
I can't really make this in Native
en because you guys have like Cuda
tensor
um no poetry
what hey that guy how's it going fixing
GPU Drive stuff
I think this has just got to be like
make uh none
right first agent about to finish its
sweep assignment very
nice
yeah just
do
if oh wait if back end is
native return M Creator or end creators
oh do we not even use that thing anymore
hold
on and ARs and
bars I think we can just use we can just
abuse um Native
right cuz I don't even know if I use
this thing do
make back end is
native oh that's Bizarro
uh yeah whatever so we'll just do it for
now I I had there's a gross thing here
it doesn't matter for now
uh okay so now we
are vector make yeah and now it's making
a native
van no attribute driver end there should
be a driver
end shouldn't there
open up
puffer oh yeah okay all we got to
do we can probably just make this thing
a puffer and yeah so we do have to do a
little bit of work here no big deal
from puffer lib
do
environment puffer
and and
then just take this gets buffer
yeah so you do actually have to use the
buffers
here that's fine we'll just refactor a
little bit for you
you and because you want stuff to be
torch tensors
terminals
locations so returns
lengths is all fine
here uh this has to return something
doesn't
[ __ ] looks like I do just return
um
huh oh because it's when you call like
async reset or
whatever
right yeah yeah it's cuz when you call a
async
reset or
whatever ASN Ki is good you may not like
it but this is what Peak Performance
looks like my
friend I think they're going to be happy
with
this and they Define step like this
right
this has been run through like black or
some other format this is weird I don't
know what this is but
whatever okay um
equals OBS s
rewards Bo self.
terminal terminal self.
fine
do oh no you don't need self infos
turn
observations rewards self.
terminals info most
likely and the rest is handled for
you and uh I'm sure we'll have to make
some fixes to this but
no really oh underscore
net there we go
um okay so in this case it's even though
it's a little odd uh we can put this at
the bottom is I think we have to put it
like
here actually I'm going to put a little
comment this
assigns bunch of buffers to
your you can't use them cuz you want for
numpy so I am
what oh yeah yeah yeah this is
fine so what we do is
kind of sketchy to be
honest but hey this is API abuse so
anything goes
dummy wa where's this
buffer end
is wait it can't be
3,876
right are any of the the GPU Drive folks
still watching
this this is the one part where it gets
a little bit domain specific
I I need to figure out
how how GPU Drive is allocating data
buffers now and how I make sure that we
match shapes
well yeah it's kind of late in uh in New
York theyve probably uh they probably
called it a night and so no big deal
I'll figure it out um Ober a shape is 24
so why why would observations be of
shape
24 uh that's interesting it should not
be
right oh self-controlled agents
Mask wait hold on
something is very weird here let me see
how I did this for you
before I
okay so we
have OBS was given to be the agents that
you
control
right then actions was given to be
all doesn't make any sense no does
it so when you reset
only given
observations agents that you
control then
actions oh no cuz it's the buffer is
controlled agents okay so I see how I
did this so I pruned out the ones that
you don't control at the start which is
totally fine it's totally fine so all
that's wrong is the uh the tensor
shape right
here actions needs to be not this shap
shape this shape is very silly this just
needs to be self. Nom
agents be an
N64
this and then we've got our
mask
Heroes and then self num agents num
agents numb agents
okay uh oh actually wait that this does
need to be a remember now so
actions
H it's kind of both isn't
it so what you need is
actions so you got your padded actions
now
do we even need self actions here I
don't think we use self. actions do we
it's kind of just
optional I think we can actually just
leave this as
there like some garbage indexing going
on
okay there are only 24 agents in
here so this is actually
correct Believe It or
Not uh this is what's going to hurt perf
the most but that's hurting perf from
adona that's for you guys to figure out
oh this parameter is not getting used um
correctly this Max controlled agents
thing is not getting used correctly at
all
wait why is
um
observations it shouldn't be that way
right
bizarre uh yeah there's garbage data in
here
Hey
Eugene how's it going so I've got this
thing you're looking at a padding tensor
I don't think I am looking at a padding
tensor though uh I'll show you so you
get your OBS right you get your
controlled agent
mask oh is it just
um is it because that even with the
controlled agent mask like there still
might be some dead agents or whatever
is that
maybe yeah this is the same problem as
before so I mean even once I get this
working you're going to be heavily
limited by the GPU Drive padding stuff
um but at least you'll have like a
standalone and I can help you iterate
from
there it's in uh the the branch Daphne
has been working on I can push this if
you want but it doesn't run it didn't
run before either so I don't know if
there's much harm to do but I'm added to
this so I can push it if you
want it's like close it's just there's a
little
yeah so there's the
issue I have made some
changes wait we have some
disagreement about whether the padding
did it cut off your question
there is needed I
assume is hurting
performance it's
definitely I mean you have let me put
this in perspective right you have 24
agents in 8 time 128 so you have 24
agents out of total of possible
1,024 I have to do a copy slice in order
to get those things into
um oh is hurting perform okay yeah we're
writing time gotcha gotcha okay I
misread it X cut your message off you
can see your message right here this is
how I see it
okay so
breakpoint this is in your container as
live do
sum okay this is weird so we have 24
agents alive so none of these should be
padding I
assume OBS is 24
uh
one let's do
huge so this guy this guy like some of
these are broken like or something it
says that they're
alive it seems like even at the start
some of these are just immediately
screwy yeah it's bad
right so I mean I can just for now just
so that you have something that runs
right I can just do like look into this
broken data I can just do
OBS OBS greater than you know 10 equal
Z OBS OBS less than
reason ASAP very
good
mix
in
interesting so except for the padding
everything's
fine rewards. Max what's or reward.
maxmin
no
rewards
terminal not sure what
is breaking the policy
I think I saw on this PR there was my
policy I actually don't remember which
policy was in the pr uh if this was my
one or your one I think I used like a
simpler
policy just to make it
faster can you set launch blocking
okay so this is likely action probs
being messed
up uh mine was permutation invariant as
well it has serious sample efficiency
did you try it versus the one that I
gave you cuz I basically just took yours
and I took like some layer Norms out and
stuff to speed it
up it was also it was still permutation
invariant in everything
to be fair it might still be sample
efficiency might be more sample
efficient but I suspect that mine is
likely a better wall
clock seriously trying puffer perfect
blank check for
support layer Norms are sometimes pretty
good training at a million steps per
second is sometimes pretty good
too and that's like uh we have like
several M's in Puffer that trained a
million and even the more complex ones
we still get like in the hundreds of
thousands yeah I mean sample efficiency
like when you have the fast Sim anyways
right
may as well just push perf per wall
clock unclear where tradeoff well what
I've done is you just like set your
hyper parameter sweep you just set the
cost to be equal to wall clock seconds
and then you let it figure it out right
you just sweep over you try different
architectures it's wall clock training
perf uh I'm trying to see where where
your thing was
here where's your policy
util okay
[Music]
so oh yeah this is my
policy so this is my policy which is
just your policy without layer norms and
slightly
simplified this is the whole
thing so this should totally be fine
then
discreet of nine should be reasonable
action space
right sell and
steer two discrete vectors I'm seeing
discrete of
nine nine is fine so I'm assuming that's
just like
merged okay um well then there shouldn't
be any
issues if that's what it's going to
be I can go check the
policy
um three yeah three we do that as well
we technically we support multi-
discreet too if you want to do multi
discreet you can do it with puffer uh
there are a couple things in the latest
version that I wanted to check to make
sure that that's good so maybe hold off
but um I mean we do support multi-
discreete and we have a bunch of multi
discreete ends
we also support we support continuous as
well uh we just don't support mixed
continuous and discreet at the moment
you got to pick
one that could be added to be fair but
hopefully not on my plate before 1.1
release we've been really busy with uh
1.1 like all these M's these are all
going to be a million plus depths per
second environments in 1
one it's like 10 15,000 lines of
C okay so we can see right here we've
got garbage in the neural net
horse it's all right I get to do this
stuff all day without having to uh worry
about publications and stuff
now I seriously think that once we
release these the next phase for puffer
is going to be like redoing the last 10
years of RL research there's your error
by the way uh redoing the last 10 years
of RL research but like with proper
evals and stuff so you get consistent
results and you're probably going to see
a lot from that okay so Road objects and
Road graphs are garbage I don't know why
this
interesting they have
m's or is this
soda
interesting they have
m's is this meta doing torch oral or
what is this
set of
M's
interesting okay they have a lot of
stuff in
here are they in
torch oh no they're
torch interesting I'll look at it I
don't know how sophisticated these are
um if they're going to just be in in
like torture Rays like
this one of the cool things with puffers
we're really not constrained on
environment complexity at all
like like we can make stuff like this
Moa
I mean we have people contributing all
sorts of Ms like we've got this like
whole tactics game M that somebody just
made that's like a full like MMO combat
type Sim we've got somebody just
contributed
go um we've got this
MOA so like one of the cool things we
can do with puffers just make really
complicated yeah this
Nathan's yeah yeah yeah this one you've
been collaborating for 5 years oh that's
awesome yeah yeah Nathan's been in here
a lot working on this he also did uh he
did our pong implementation too puffer
pong and then we've got a couple new big
projects I have one other big project
coming in the works and then also we've
got uh there's a new collab that's going
to be on this TCG this like magic the
Gathering style en uh which I'm I have
hopes for I made this prototype of it
just to see you know how far I could get
really quickly with it um but yeah we're
going to have like build this out and
stuff loves wri in
Sims it's gotten really way easier to do
high perf stuff in uh in puffer like I
don't know if you've taken a look at all
at these ends but like this is actually
a very very legit option now um because
essentially like because vectorization
is now fast and because we have good
Integrations end to end with
vectorization
right we can kind of just start writing
generic code and have it be fast so like
uh I don't know what's a good example
the Moa here which would be like a
pretty substantial software project
right well it's one file it's 2,000
lines of c and you can just read it top
to bottom and it's pretty brain dead
like there's absolutely nothing
surprising in here it's just really
simple procedural code all the way
through um simpler example would be
like what's like
decent I guess like
pong pong. H 300 lines including a bunch
of extra logging stuff so really like
250 lines and just very simple little
procedural
logic observations and everything obs
ation get computed directly into shared
memory runs millions of steps per second
don't have to like write Vector code you
just get to write normal like normal
loops and stuff so very nice for
that wrote nocturn in C++ for similar
reasons never ran faster than
6K um
I don't actually know how
intensive of computations you have going
on in
there it could be that I
mean I like C because it's it's like so
simple it's actually kind of hard to
shoot yourself in the foot like there
are no malaks there is no memory
allocation dynamically during uh the Run
um it's all static memory so that helps
a lot
um I mean we don't have stuff like
vector that can like dynamically resize
we don't have a lot of things it it's
pretty much just Loops over static
arrays and
[Music]
memory I'd have to actually get like if
you're interested in like trying to
figure out how to do this type of thing
really high perf I could look at it and
basically I would just need to know like
what the slow Parts in theory of the
nvar like what are the parts that
actually like require flops in theory
and then I'd have to figure out how fast
those pieces can run single thread
that's all I would have to
do do you have any idea why the uh the
ego state is good but these things are
like way out of
bounds so I can just fix this up for you
real quick and I can send you over a uh
a nice thing to to play with tomorrow so
you can play with this
tomorrow GPU Drive doesn't feel yeah no
well I don't know where your lab is
going with the Future Sims and stuff but
you know the simulated M for research
game has gotten a lot
easier not obvious what's wrong with it
it's particularly weird
because I
mean how is the data even getting in the
policy like
that
oh shouldn't be able to do
that is it just wrong at the first step
I think
so I mean you have this unpack function
don't
you it algorithm puffer
utils where is
unpack reshape this is just a reshape
though this doesn't scale
right so if this is just a reshape then
uh my scaling should have fixed this for
you unless it's getting like one
hunted
uh every agent that has nonsense OBS
let's
see I don't know let's see
later yeah so it's just a few of them it
looks like but the thing is I thought I
accounted for
that oh I didn't account for it in reset
I'm stupid one second I forgot to do it
in reset my
here so OBS do we even right into OBS
here
wait
grand total of 470 steps per
second um but I have the settings very
low
um I'll leave some comments in the file
basically you had the settings too high
like it was too many worlds with too
many Max agents you got to do some stuff
with that um I have it running at the
very least
now I mean this is purely
settings I can try to get something a
bit more reasonable for you here
okay um so I changed a few things I got
to push a new update to puffer for you
to make this work there was like 90% I
had to fix stuff in in here but I did
have to fix a couple things in puffer um
just because we have like this new n
format and I'm using the thing that used
to be called native for that now um I
made your en under the native format now
it's a puffer en um it matches like Jim
VEC format roughly it this should be
fine uh yeah this should be fine don't
try to multiprocess it don't try to make
it serial or whatever it's a GPU M run
it on GPU that'll get you several
100,000 SPS if you want to multiprocess
it we can figure out how to multiprocess
it after it shouldn't be that hard um I
will have to change a couple things and
the Cuda tensors will have to go through
numpy if you want to do that though so
we'll do that after um the only other
thing for you was where was the the
config baselines run
yeah so I set this
thing it okay so I set these all to one
which is what they should be and I think
it's actually in the end file and num
worlds is only eight
so yeah that's so
slow I mean look you've got 70 some odd
time in the
en
um so what's happening here is like it's
padded to 128 agents the scene is very
sparse right so like the actual batch
size coming out of madona is Tiny uh you
need like dense agents so get those
timings St up but now you got the puffer
harness can I just push this to this
Branch or do you want me to I can put
this in a new Branch actually
slash smoke
tested puer
PP B
focus on training Den scenes I you know
you really should be able to at the
engine level just have those tensors be
configur like you should be able to do
something with that but whatever for the
time being puffer NS puffer
po uh didn't
there I
change guess that's all I
changed yeah
kind of should be able to return a flat
tensor yeah exactly and even then
like got to work on having those scenes
like be denser like the agents got to
not die so much insist on it yeah I mean
I can probably come up with some ways to
make that easier to do depends how deep
into madon it is oh I talked to uh to
Brennan on uh I talked to like the
madona folks at Stanford uh last week
couple weeks ago whatever um so I think
we can probably end up supporting a lot
more of these GPU madona
M get to 80% pretty fast and then they
don't die often 80% would be fine like
the problem is a lot of the runs I've
seen for here have been like 5% and then
the like it's 95% just idle
okay so there's your PR or your your
branch because I think they just gave me
access to do
that
um is
this and I'll post it in the
slack I'll get you your uh your other
commit real quick as well
us oh do I not even change
anything I thought I
actually yeah I guess I didn't change
anything I think you're
good never mind I was smarter than I
thought
here uh whoops uh my bad leaking slack
on stream
there I don't think you need latest
puffer or anything uh I forgot that I
just had to change your rapper not
puffer
rapper all right well I think uh if
that's all for tonight I'm going to
maybe do a couple quick things on the
mooba and then uh call a night after uh
get some exercise get some food called a
night
um yeah I mean just let me know how this
integration goes and and I'll be able to
help on that you can just like you can
message me on the slack but more likely
if you want instant if you just want
instant feedback just send students over
to stream and you get instant answers to
stuff and uh I'm more than happy to like
pull stuff on pull stuff up live and fix
things like this I have the container
now this is just your GPU
container uh
yeah we should be good with
that I really still hope that there's
you know I really hope that there's
eventually a way that we could do like I
don't know compile all of Madrona to a
web assembly or something so you can
like stick GPU Drive online that' just
be awesome I've done it for a lot of my
M's and like if it's just steering an
acceleration you could literally map the
cars to the keyboard so like you know
you can take over for the agents and see
if you can drive better than the agents
that's how we have it
here uh obviously we don't have it like
the website needs a redesign and stuff
but like here like this is a Connect 4
agent that's pretty darn good I can hold
shift and it'll stop playing and then I
can like you know take over for the
agent and like try to beat it on stuff
uh right like I can try to beat
it Unity
setup Drive in
VR that's
cool I think the biggest thing honestly
is just compiling for web assembly just
having it in the browser has been so
nice I mean like literally like look
here's the agent playing pong it's
pretty good at pong right and then like
you can just hold shift and now I'm
playing it and now I can see like oh
actually this is kind of hard to do
better than the agent is right so it's
just like very instant gratification for
Stuff
very very hard to drive with a keyboard
Grand Theft
wheel it's only three dire it's if
it'sit a discreet of nine isn't that
just like W
WD with like the key not being pressed
is
all
right see you around thank you
by all right we go back to GPU drive for
a bit I mean uh PR MOA for a
bit see if I can fix this ah 20 minutes
or so see you
Moa oh I I need to be on the
box yeah I remember I
okay so this is where we were uh yeah I
remember
um we were trying to figure out when you
take a tower or when you scan a tower
okay what's up here so scan
Tower at
106 that was like instantaneous
really player zero scan Tower
106 I don't know how he got over there
that fast but
okay oh is there something wrong with
player
zero that's kind of weird that it's
always player zero
oh no no no no because this is yeah it's
it's their own base
right wait but hold on 106 is X no
that's the enemy base how' they get over
there
it if it's scanning the tower it should
be moving towards
it's funny how with the replies on uh on
x people always assume when I say C I'm
I mean C++ no I mean writing C it's
zero one is dire tow Towers
alive Tower
they both have no Towers alive that
makes no
sense well cuz you're dumb is why this
is zero
okay this will be a little bit more
informative
logs 12 dire Towers
alive so dire got all their
radiant has like no Towers because at
the end of the
game lots are programmed to basically
take all of
them
right they've won all the games yeah
this is exactly as it looks and then
randomly out of the blue we're going to
get a victory for uh radiant right
yeah there you go
so I mean according to this thing you
got a radiant
got both of these relatively close to
the enemy ancient but this player zero
right next to it but I don't think it's
just a player zero bug because we've
seen other ones close to it and like
this is pretty close too
um man did they just get like teleported
here or something let me see cuz like
Tower
X okay so Tower
Team 1 2 3 four five 6 7 8 nine so the
first nine
Towers is 0 through
8 well one the mid Tower I assume this
is the mid tower Tower nine
here so
and five
six oh no this is top Tower isn't
it or this
is wait 1 two 3 4 5 6 7 8
n huh
no yeah 10 so it's
103 and then one two three four five
six
wait Tower 22 wait wait there's a clue
there isn't
there wait Tower
anybody wait Tower y Tower X player y
player
X so what player 20 wait player three is
the one that's close by right
at
Y 107 so yeah it's literally right on
top of it player three
is player three is a level 20
n which character is player three is it
the
tank yeah it's the
tank so
somehow right the tank gets all the way
over there
we're actually not even all that close
to the enemy
Tower enemy
ancient but they've taken like
everything
else who the heck is defending
why aren't they all the way at the
ancient
let me Commit This current thing right
here actually
here they
come here's Ultra fast MOBA
mode ah I'm getting
wrecked
okay here comes their
tank oh what the heck killed the
tank the tower
okay here comes their
tank okay so our Towers defend the tank
against the tank they do a decent
job
yeah he's level 13 now he's level
16 and then that resets the end
right does the tank get stuck somewhere
or something
tank so top laner strong very strong
right
regen do they regen I know why they
don't regen much either way I don't
think they regen at
all CU it got to be like some weird Edge
case where like despawning an agent or
some
[ __ ]
because otherwise
like how
you can also see like that this Tower is
starting to take some damage as
Tower uh do we check status on
Towers cuz this is kind of weird
could that mess something
up I don't think
so there's the there he
is he has taking our
Tower update cool cool Downs yeah
there's no update status or
anything yeah there's no stun check on a
tower
oh uh that didn't reset the
game well there's your problem
game doesn't
huh I thought I'd fix that a while
ago but yeah so what's going to happen
is eventually like you run this thing
for long enough then yeah eventually
like uh our team is going to power Farm
up that's crazy he's still getting hit I
think isn't
he I mean this is the damage
now this shows you the importance of
rendering the freaking game and playing
it I'm going to see if I spot it real
quick and if not I'm going to call it a
day and we'll know for tomorrow where to
breaks if this doesn't break I'm not
going to put any more thought in for the
night I'm just going to launch a
training run see what happens
damn
it that's
weird it still happens it looks like cuz
they're at the
base um
yeah that's
disappointing I mean are they able to
heal it or some [ __ ]
try this last
one last one for the
powers and this is about what we
want let's see if it
breaks if so yeah okay so
there's there's some weird Edge
case um where every some number of games
not even that rare to be
honest uh it's possible that like the
game win or game over condition doesn't
happening yeah um I'm going to call it
here I'm going to figure this out
tomorrow we at least got a visual Repro
of what's
Happening we know what the issue is this
is probably the main thing preventing
all the training frankly because this is
going to happen very early on in
training and then there's nothing to
learn because you know all your games
eventually just get stuck in limbo um
all right thanks folks I will uh
probably continue on this on stream in
the morning all the usual things if you
haven't already all free and open source
on puffer lib uh GitHub
here please go ahead and give that a
star really helps us out a ton uh if
you're interested Ed in contributing to
this discord.gg puffer lots of new
contributors on there onboarding new
folks all the time and if you're looking
for reinforcement learning and adjacent
Tech